Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. A strict observance of the great traditions of the sea towards women and children reflects nothing but honor upon our civilization. Even I hope it may mollify some of the young, unmarried lady teachers who are so bitter in their sex antagonism and think men so base and vile. I cannot help feeling proud of our race and its traditions, as proved by this event. Boatloads of women and children tossing on the sea, safe and sound,
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、享受无广告收听体验、抢先观看系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。在海上严格遵守对待妇女和儿童的伟大传统，这只会为我们的文明增光添彩。我甚至希望这能安抚那些年轻、未婚的女教师，她们对性别对立怀有如此强烈的怨恨，认为男人如此卑劣和下流。我不禁为我们的种族及其传统感到自豪，这一事件证明了这一点。满载妇女和儿童的救生艇在海上颠簸，安然无恙，
and the rest, silence, honour to their memory. In spite of all the inequalities and artificialities of our modern life, at the bottom, tested to its foundations, our civilization is humane, Christian, and absolutely democratic. How differently Imperial Rome or Ancient Greece would have settled the problem. The swells and potentates would have gone off with their concubines and pet slaves and soldier guards, and whoever could bribe the crew would have had the preference and the rest could go to hell. But such ethics could neither build titanics with science nor lose them with honour. So that, of course, was Winston Churchill.
其余的，唯有沉默，向他们的记忆致敬。尽管我们现代生活中存在种种不平等和虚伪，但归根结底，在经受住考验时，我们的文明是人道的、基督教的，并且是绝对民主的。帝国罗马或古希腊会以多么不同的方式解决这个问题。权贵和显要们会带着他们的妃嫔、宠物奴隶和卫兵逃之夭夭，任何能贿赂船员的人都会获得优先权，而其他人则可以去死。但这样的道德既不能用科学建造泰坦尼克号，也不能在失去它时保持荣誉。所以，这当然是温斯顿·丘吉尔所言。
And he was writing a letter, Tom, to his wife Clementine after he'd been reading about the loss of the Titanic on the 15th of April, 1912. And it's very Churchill, isn't it? To have a go at unmarried lady teachers. Yes. At the beginning. Yes, so I hope any feminists out there listening to this will feel themselves put in their place. But also to congratulate Britain and the Anglo-Saxon race, as he would have called it,
汤姆，这是他在1912年4月15日读到泰坦尼克号沉没的消息后写给妻子克莱门汀的一封信。这非常有丘吉尔的风格，不是吗？去抨击那些未婚的女教师。是的。在开头。是的，所以我希望听到这段话的女权主义者们会觉得她们被摆在了应有的位置。但同时也要祝贺英国和盎格鲁-撒克逊种族，正如他所称呼的那样，
on their splendid performance in the Titanic drama. So the fact that Britain's most expensive and largest ship has sunk to the bottom of the ocean is a tremendous reflection. Hurrah for us. But also to offer some thoughts about history, profound historical lessons. So Churchill says, Tom, that the men of Imperial Rome or ancient Greece, the swells and potentates,
在泰坦尼克号这场大戏中的出色表现。所以，英国最昂贵、最大的船沉入海底这一事实，是一个巨大的反思。为我们欢呼吧。但也要提供一些关于历史的思考，深刻的历史教训。所以丘吉尔说，汤姆，帝国罗马或古希腊的男人们，那些权贵和显要们，
would have gone off with their concubines, their slaves, their soldiers, their eunuchs and whatnot, and the rest could go to hell. That's probably true, isn't it? He's not wrong. Well, I think it's an insane argument to have. If the Romans had built it. I think rather than try and answer that question, which I think is essentially unanswerable
会带着他们的妃嫔、奴隶、士兵、太监之类的逃走，而其他人则可以去死。这大概是真的，不是吗？他没说错。嗯，我认为这是一个疯狂的争论。如果罗马人建造了它。我想与其试图回答那个问题，我认为这本质上是无法回答的，
or very, very complex. You know he's right. You know he's right. It's a fascinating example of the way in which the moment the ship sinks, people start projecting their political opinions, their cultural assumptions, the narrative that they want onto it. So in another letter, Churchill says to Clemmie that it's a very good story. And that sense right from the beginning, this is an incredible story. That influences the way that the news is received. But before we get onto that, how the story of the Titanic comes to be understood, should we just, as it were, literally pick up from where we left off?
或者非常、非常复杂。你知道他是对的。你知道他是对的。这是一个迷人的例子，说明了船沉没的那一刻，人们就开始将他们的政治观点、文化假设以及他们想要的叙事投射到它身上。所以在另一封信中，丘吉尔对克莱米说这是一个非常好的故事。从一开始就有这种感觉，这是一个不可思议的故事。这影响了新闻被接收的方式。但在我们进入那个话题之前，关于泰坦尼克号的故事是如何被理解的，我们是否应该，正如我们所说，从我们离开的地方继续讲起？
We've got lots of people bobbing around in lifeboats and the ship that comes to their rescue a couple of hours too late is the Carpathia, isn't it? Cunard, of all things. So Cunard, they're great rifles. And Dominic, it's Captain. So you have gone on record as being a big fan of Captain Smith. Huge fan. And in fact, as we sit here recording this,
我们有很多在救生艇上漂浮的人，而几个小时后赶来救援他们的船是卡帕西亚号，不是吗？卡纳德航运公司的船。所以卡纳德，他们真是了不起。多米尼克，那是船长。所以你已经公开表示你是史密斯船长的忠实粉丝。超级粉丝。事实上，当我们坐在这里录制这段节目时，
you have as your name on the screen, Captain Smith. Tommy, you're giving too many insights to the listeners into our working methods. But we now come to another captain, and I will leave the listeners to decide which of us this captain sounds like. So this is a man called Arthur Rostron, who is the captain of the Carpathia, small Cuyunada, carrying 743 passengers, three days out of New York, heading for Gibraltar and Mediterranean ports beyond that. And one of the officers on the ship says of Rostron, I had the greatest respect for him as a seaman, a disciplinarian, and as a man who could take a decision quickly.
你的屏幕上的名字是史密斯船长。汤米，你向听众透露了太多关于我们工作方式的信息。但我们现在要谈到另一位船长，我会让听众来决定这位船长听起来像我们中的哪一位。这是一个名叫亚瑟·罗斯特龙的人，他是卡帕西亚号的船长，一艘小型卡纳德邮轮，载有743名乘客，离开纽约三天，正前往直布罗陀和更远的地中海港口。船上的一名军官这样评价罗斯特龙：作为一名海员、一名纪律严明的人，以及一个能迅速做出决定的人，我对他怀有最大的敬意。
He was not the burly type of jolly old sea dog, Dominic. Far from it. He was a thin and wiry build with sharp features, piercing blue eyes and rapid agile movements. Well, Tom, I hear you. The sad thing, though, is that everybody remembers Captain Smith, but nobody's ever heard of the other man. Well, this is what the rest of history is about.
多米尼克，他不是那种粗犷、快乐的老海狗。远非如此。他身材瘦削而结实，五官轮廓分明，有着锐利的蓝眼睛和敏捷的动作。嗯，汤姆，我听到了。但可悲的是，每个人都记得史密斯船长，却从来没有人听说过另一个人。嗯，这就是《历史的余味》的意义所在。
And, of course, Captain Smith is the only one of those two characters who's played by the same person who played Théoden, King of Rohan. So, listeners can indeed draw their own conclusions from the Théoden and Denethor-like dynamic that's going on there. Right, so Rostron is the captain of the Carpathia. We said last time, didn't we, that his wireless operator was just going to bed. He was literally taking his boots off. He's got his headphones on because he's listening for acknowledgement of a message that he sent.
当然，史密斯船长是这两个角色中唯一一个由扮演洛汗国王希优顿的演员所饰演的人。所以，听众确实可以从那里发生的希优顿和迪耐瑟式的动态中得出自己的结论。好吧，所以罗斯特龙是卡帕西亚号的船长。我们上次说过，他的无线电操作员正准备睡觉，不是吗？他当时正脱掉靴子。他戴着耳机，因为他在监听他发出的消息的确认信号。
And he hears, actually what he hears, I misspoke in the last episode. I said he heard their transmissions. He doesn't. He hears transmissions that are from Cape Cod going to Titanic, basically saying, you know, how are you getting on? Have you sunk yet? So he then sends a message to Titanic saying, what's going on? I'm on my way. And they say, come at once.
他听到了，实际上他听到的是，我在上一集中说错了。我说他听到了他们的传输。他没有。他听到的是从科德角发往泰坦尼克号的传输，基本上是在说，你知道，你们进展如何？你们沉了吗？所以他随后给泰坦尼克号发了一条消息，问发生了什么事？我正在赶来。他们说，快来。
We struck an iceberg. You're absolutely right to praise Captain Rostrum because he basically says right get everything ready they get there in three and a half hours they're firing rockets to say help is coming and they've got all their life boats ready and all of that kind of thing they got all their crew ready to haul these guys up and actually they perform splendidly don't't they? Tremendously. And they actually see the iceberg, which I hadn't realised. Yeah, a double-toothed iceberg, they describe it as, don't they? Yeah, double-toothed, looking very menacing. A hundred feet high, yeah.
我们撞上了一座冰山。你赞扬罗斯特龙船长是完全正确的，因为他基本上说，好，让一切准备就绪，他们在三个半小时内赶到了那里，他们发射火箭以示救援正在赶来，他们准备好了所有的救生艇，诸如此类的事情，他们让所有的船员准备好把这些人拉上来，实际上他们表现得非常出色，不是吗？非常出色。而且他们实际上看到了那座冰山，我之前没意识到。是的，他们将其描述为一座双齿冰山，不是吗？是的，双齿，看起来非常险恶。一百英尺高，是的。
Yeah. As they bring the survivors on board, Rostron says, the thing that strikes him is they are silent. There's no noise, no hurry. They came solemnly, dumbly out of a shivering shadow. I mean, they are broken. They're traumatized. They're frozen. I mean, they're incredibly cold. And among the traumatized is Ismay. Yes. Who is not saying a word. He's given a sedative, isn't he? And he basically stays hidden in the ship's doctor's cabin. The billionaire's
是的。当他们把幸存者带上船时，罗斯特龙说，让他印象深刻的是他们很沉默。没有噪音，没有匆忙。他们庄严地、木然地从颤抖的阴影中走出来。我的意思是，他们崩溃了。他们受到了创伤。他们冻僵了。我的意思是，他们冷得难以置信。在受创伤的人中就有伊斯梅。是的。他一言不发。他被注射了镇静剂，不是吗？他基本上一直躲在船医的船舱里。亿万富翁的
widows, so Asta, Thea, Widener, they're given cabins. By and large, they're put in the dining rooms and doctors are kind of going around, sort of sorting them out, giving them, I don't know, brandy or whatever they would do. And the terrible stories of mothers with very small babies having to use napkins as nappies or diapers as Americans would call it. Oh God, yeah. Anyway, but at least they're alive dominic yes what about the dead so maybe a little bit of a survey of their dead we don't know
遗孀们，比如阿斯特、泰亚、怀德纳，她们被安置在船舱里。总的来说，她们被安置在餐厅里，医生们四处走动，整理她们，给她们，我不知道，白兰地或者他们会做的任何事情。还有那些带着非常小的婴儿的母亲不得不使用餐巾纸作为尿布的恐怖故事，美国人会称之为尿布。哦，天哪，是的。无论如何，但至少她们还活着，多米尼克。是的，那死者呢？所以也许对死者做一个小小的调查，我们不知道
exactly how many people died because we don't know exactly how many people are on the ship so the u.s official u.s estimate is 1517 people the The official British estimate is 1,503 people. Somewhere in between those two figures seems reasonable. And 700 of those are members of the crew. Yes, that's right. The biggest loss of life in maritime history other than in battle to that point. And in Britain, it's a greater loss of life
到底有多少人死亡，因为我们不知道船上到底有多少人。所以美国官方的估计是1517人。英国官方的估计是1503人。在这两个数字之间似乎是合理的。其中700人是船员。是的，没错。这是海事史上除战争外最大的生命损失。在英国，这是更大的生命损失
than the British had lost in any of the battles of the Boer War, which was the last big war they had fought. And actually, Richard Davenport Hines in his book, Titanic Lives, has really dug into the stats about why you live and why you die. And it is pretty clear that you live if you're a woman and you die if you're a man. That's much more important than class. But there is a slight class. Oh, there is an absolutely a class dimension. But if you're a third class woman, you are far more likely to survive than a first class man. But having said that, out of 324 first class passengers, 201 survive. Yes. Out of 277 second class passengers, 118 survive.
比英国在布尔战争的任何一场战役中损失的人数都要多，那是他们打过的最后一场大战。事实上，理查德·达文波特·海恩斯在他的书《泰坦尼克号的生命》中真正深入研究了关于你为什么活着、为什么死亡的统计数据。很明显，如果你是女性，你就会活下来，如果你是男性，你就会死亡。这比阶级重要得多。但确实有一点阶级因素。哦，绝对有一个阶级维度。但如果你是一名三等舱女性，你比一等舱男性更有可能幸存。但话虽如此，在324名一等舱乘客中，有201人幸存。是的。在277名二等舱乘客中，有118人幸存。
Out of 708 third class, 181 survive. Yeah. And I think a lot of this, the general sense is that a lot of this is determined by access to the boat deck. So first class passengers are closer. They have more stewards assigned to them per person, stewards who are getting them to the boat deck. So first class passengers are closer. They have more stewards assigned to them per person, stewards who are getting them to the decks. Of course, we described in the last episode how the gates are left closed, blocking third class passengers from getting up.
在708名三等舱乘客中，有181人幸存。是的。我认为这其中很大一部分，普遍的感觉是这很大程度上取决于进入甲板的通道。所以一等舱乘客离得更近。他们每人分配了更多的乘务员，乘务员会带他们去甲板。所以一等舱乘客离得更近。他们每人分配了更多的乘务员，乘务员会带他们去甲板。当然，我们在上一集中描述了闸门是如何保持关闭的，阻挡了三等舱乘客上去。
But not deliberately, just to reiterate that. Not deliberately, but for about half an hour or so, I think. So they're open about 12.30, aren't they? Yes. So actually longer than half an hour, in other words. It's about 45 minutes. If you're in a large family, you're more likely to die because large families- Are not going to break up. Yeah. And just to give the gender figures, Dominic, 74.3% of female passengers survive, 52.3% of children survive, 20% of men survive. Yeah. So that gives you a sense. And of course, basically what you want to be is a first class woman because 97% of them live.
但不是故意的，只是重申一下。不是故意的，但大约半小时左右，我想。所以它们在12点30分左右打开，不是吗？是的。所以实际上比半小时长，换句话说。大约45分钟。如果你在一个大家庭里，你更有可能死亡，因为大家庭——不会分开。是的。为了给出性别数据，多米尼克，74.3%的女性乘客幸存，52.3%的儿童幸存，20%的男性幸存。是的。所以这让你有个概念。当然，基本上你想成为的是一等舱女性，因为她们中97%的人活了下来。
Yeah. In third class, it's dropped to 47%. But that, as we said, is probably because of distance. One other thing that's really interesting is why the figure's not better for second class passengers. Because they actually have easier access to the deck than third class passengers. And Richard Davenport Hines suggests that actually there may be an element of second-class passengers. So these are people who are never featured in the film and popular accounts. These are your clergymen, your shopkeepers.
是的。在三等舱，这个比例下降到47%。但正如我们所说，这可能是因为距离。还有一件事非常有趣，那就是为什么二等舱乘客的数字没有更好。因为他们实际上比三等舱乘客更容易进入甲板。理查德·达文波特·海恩斯认为，实际上二等舱乘客可能有一个因素。所以这些人是电影和流行叙述中从未出现过的人。这些是你的牧师、你的店主。
They are the people who are most likely to be conformist, obedient, to hang back, to be anxious about doing the wrong thing. And so that probably is what dooms so many of them. They are by definition- Not pushy. Yeah, not pushy. Exactly. Okay. So should we look at how the news reaches the world? Because there are all kinds of places across the Atlantic, both sides, that have a particular stake in it. So New York, obviously, which is a destination, Washington, the center of American power,
他们是最有可能循规蹈矩、顺从、退缩、担心做错事的人。所以这可能就是导致他们中许多人注定失败的原因。他们根据定义——不爱出风头。是的，不爱出风头。没错。好吧。那我们来看看新闻是如何传遍世界的？因为大西洋两岸有很多地方对此有特殊的利害关系。所以纽约，显然，这是一个目的地，华盛顿，美国权力的中心，
London, Belfast, Liverpool, Southampton. How does the news reach them? So the first hint of the disaster reaches the Marconi outpost in Newfoundland, Cape Race. And then it is transported to a steamship headquarters in Montreal. And that gives it to a Montreal newspaper, and that newspaper has an agreement with the New York Times.
伦敦、贝尔法斯特、利物浦、南安普敦。新闻是如何传到他们那里的？所以灾难的第一个迹象传到了纽芬兰的马可尼前哨站，开普雷斯。然后它被运送到蒙特利尔的一家轮船总部。然后它把它给了蒙特利尔的一家报纸，而那家报纸与《纽约时报》有协议。
So at 2 o'clock in the morning, a journalist from the New York Times telephones the American vice president of the International Mercantile Marine, so the holding company, the umbrella company, and he says, is this true? Philip Franklin, the guy's name, is the vice president of IMM. And for the rest of monday actually the guy from imm is is really bullish he says it's indestructible maybe there's been
所以在凌晨2点，一名《纽约时报》的记者打电话给国际商业海运公司（即控股公司、伞形公司）的美国副总裁，他说，这是真的吗？菲利普·富兰克林，那个人的名字，是IMM的副总裁。而在周一剩下的时间里，实际上来自IMM的那个人非常乐观，他说它是坚不可摧的，也许发生了一点
a mishap but it's unsinkable they are telling people all day don't worry no cause for alarm and it's actually not until the monday evening so of course all this had happened on Sunday, Sunday night, early hours of Monday, it's not until Monday evening that they have confirmation that the ship has sunk and that hundreds of people have been killed. And they are just... So not good for the share price?
小事故，但它是永不沉没的。他们整天都在告诉人们，别担心，没有理由惊慌。直到周一晚上，当然所有这些都发生在周日、周日晚上、周一凌晨，直到周一晚上他们才确认船已经沉没，数百人已经遇难。他们只是……所以对股价不利？
Not good for the share price at all. And the news spreads through the United States quite quickly. President Taft in Washington, when he finds out that Archie Butt is not among the survivors, he is floods of tears. No one to laugh
对股价一点也不利。新闻在美国传得很快。华盛顿的塔夫脱总统，当他发现阿奇·巴特不在幸存者名单中时，他泪流满面。没有人可以笑
at his golf jokes or cheer him up when people call him fatty. Or to eat those terrible lunches with him. Yeah. Pickles and mustard or something.
他的高尔夫笑话，或者在他被称为胖子时让他振作起来。或者和他一起吃那些糟糕的午餐。是的。泡菜和芥末之类的。
Anyway, he has all flags at half-mast, doesn't he, in the United united states official flags he does yes reflecting the scale of the loss of life and in britain it comes to poldu doesn't it the uh marconi station in cornwall which you can still visit to this day and um so it's in the london evening papers monday night titanic sinking but at this point it's only in the next few days that the extent of the disaster
无论如何，他让所有旗帜降半旗，不是吗，在美国，官方旗帜，他确实这样做了，反映了生命损失的规模。而在英国，它传到了波尔杜，不是吗，康沃尔的马可尼站，你至今仍可以参观，所以周一晚上的伦敦晚报报道了泰坦尼克号沉没，但此时，只有在接下来的几天里，灾难的程度
becomes apparent because at first a lot of the papers britain is a country at that point with you know very very successful regional newspapers in places like liverpool belfast southampton that will be deeply affected and the early editions of those papers say everybody has been saved. Very few people have died. And they give people kind of false hope. Now, Tom, you will know we have a Restless History Club, don't we? We do. And that community manager, James, is a very big fan of HH Asquith. He loves Asquith. Indeed, his nickname is Asquith. He was prime minister at the time. He's got a t-shirt with Asquith's face on it, Tom.
才变得明显，因为起初很多报纸，英国当时是一个拥有非常、非常成功的地区性报纸的国家，在利物浦、贝尔法斯特、南安普敦等地方，这些地方会受到深远的影响，而这些报纸的早期版本说每个人都获救了。很少有人死亡。他们给了人们一种虚假的希望。现在，汤姆，你会知道我们有一个《历史的余味》俱乐部，不是吗？我们有。那位社区经理詹姆斯是H.H.阿斯奎斯的超级粉丝。他热爱阿斯奎斯。确实，他的绰号就是阿斯奎斯。他当时是首相。他有一件印有阿斯奎斯脸的T恤，汤姆。
Would you believe? Asquith lets himself down, doesn't he? By weeping over breakfast. You think that's poor? You think that's unchurchillian? I think it's unmanly. Yeah. The complete lack of a stiff upper lip. Unmanly. So he does, because by Friday, the British newspaper said reports that Carpathia has arrived with the survivors. And so they now know pretty much exactly who has survived and who hasn't and Asquith and his wife Margo cry at breakfast reading the papers and then that evening Asquith has moved into a new house on the banks of the Thames and his children all turn up that evening for a housewarming party and they do what people
你敢相信吗？阿斯奎斯让自己失望了，不是吗？在早餐时哭泣。你认为这很糟糕吗？你认为这不符合丘吉尔的风格吗？我认为这不像个男人。是的。完全缺乏坚毅的性格。不像男人。所以他确实这样做了，因为到周五，英国报纸报道说卡帕西亚号带着幸存者抵达了。所以他们现在几乎确切地知道谁幸存了，谁没有。阿斯奎斯和他的妻子玛戈在早餐时读着报纸哭泣，然后那天晚上阿斯奎斯搬进了泰晤士河畔的一所新房子，他的孩子们那天晚上都来参加乔迁派对，他们做了人们
I think should always do at housewarming parties which is they read out incredibly moving and traumatic stories about the titanic from the papers to each other and all cry yeah sob over the bold eggs yes but i mean i suppose the place that that is most affected is southampton isn't it because lots of the crew have come from there yes i can't remember who it is compares it to you know a mining community where there's been some terrible tragedy and lots of lives have been lost underground or something yeah that the scale of the disaster it reaches across the entire city it does indeed yeah southampton a classic example of one of these places where the newspapers have reports that everybody's alive the southern daily echo for some hours great anxiety prevailed but fortunately more reassuring tidings reached us this afternoon when all passengers were
我认为在乔迁派对上总是应该做的事情，那就是他们互相朗读报纸上关于泰坦尼克号的令人动容和创伤性的故事，然后都哭了，是的，对着煮鸡蛋啜泣。是的，但我想受影响最严重的地方是南安普敦，不是吗？因为很多船员都来自那里。是的，我不记得是谁把它比作一个矿区，那里发生了一些可怕的悲剧，很多生命在地下丧生之类的。是的，灾难的规模，它波及了整个城市。确实如此，是的，南安普敦是这些地方的一个典型例子，报纸报道说每个人都活着，《南方每日回声报》报道说，几个小时来，人们充满了极大的焦虑，但幸运的是，今天下午传来了更令人放心的消息，所有乘客都
reported to be safe. And then the next day they say, actually, that wasn't correct. Yeah, corrections. When we said that. And the vast majority of the crew live in Southampton. And about, is it 700 of them have died? Yeah. So there's an example of one school in Southampton, 125 children lose either a brother, a father, or an uncle. Yeah.
据报道是安全的。然后第二天他们说，实际上，那是不正确的。是的，更正。当我们说那个的时候。绝大多数船员住在南安普敦。大约，是700人死亡吗？是的。所以有一个南安普敦学校的例子，125名儿童失去了兄弟、父亲或叔叔。是的。
The whole city is plunged into grief and mourning. Same story actually in Liverpool. So a lot of those men have actually come originally from Liverpool they'd moved to Southampton when White Star had moved so Liverpool 2 is a city that has lost hundreds of people and there's basically an entire city in mourning and the name of Liverpool is on the ship yeah so people who've seen the film will remember this is you know it's on the end of the ship as it prepares to plunge down so there's a sense of humiliation there as well. And there is also a sense of humiliation in Belfast, which had built it. Oh, Belfast, yeah.
整个城市陷入了悲伤和哀悼。利物浦的情况实际上也是一样。所以很多那些人实际上最初来自利物浦，当白星航运公司搬迁时，他们搬到了南安普敦，所以利物浦也是一个失去了数百人的城市，基本上整个城市都在哀悼，而且利物浦的名字就在船上。是的，所以看过电影的人会记得，这是，你知道，它在船准备沉没时就在船尾，所以那里也有某种羞辱感。贝尔法斯特也有羞辱感，是它建造了这艘船。哦，贝尔法斯特，是的。
And the fact that this unsinkable ship, the pride of the Harland and Wolfe shipyards, built by Ulster Protestants, has sunk, is felt as a kind of political humiliation, isn't it, for Protestantism in Ulster? I think it is because Harland and Wolfe and shipyards, they weren't just a symbol of the city, but they're a symbol of a kind of industrial ethic that the people of that city believed they had. See, they believed, in that episode that we did about number two in this series, the people of Belfast, the Protestant people of Belfast believed we are different from our neighbours. We work harder. We are more
事实上，这艘永不沉没的船，哈兰德和沃尔夫造船厂的骄傲，由阿尔斯特新教徒建造，已经沉没，这被认为是一种政治羞辱，不是吗，对于阿尔斯特的新教徒来说？我认为是这样，因为哈兰德和沃尔夫以及造船厂，它们不仅是城市的象征，而且是该市人民认为他们所拥有的某种工业道德的象征。你看，他们相信，在我们这个系列第二集中我们做的那一集里，贝尔法斯特的人民，贝尔法斯特的新教徒相信我们与邻居不同。我们工作更努力。我们更
industrious. We are more, you know, all of this kind of stuff, which, you know, people will raise their eyebrows at now, I guess. And at a time when they are sort of being ripped apart by the great ructions about home rule and the sectarian violence and stuff, for this to happen at this moment makes it all the more powerful again the sense of a metaphor yeah hoving into view yeah absolutely very difficult to resist that kind of conclusion isn't it totally because the moment it sinks people are stirred by the story in all kinds of ways often in kind of quite mad ways because there are people who kind of lay claim to the fact that they've lost relatives on the ship and they haven't at all and all this i mean yeah you've seen this guy
勤奋。我们更，你知道，所有这些东西，我想现在人们会对此挑眉。而在他们正被关于地方自治和宗派暴力等重大冲突撕裂的时候，这件事在这一刻发生，使得它更加强大，再次成为一种隐喻，是的，出现在视野中。是的，绝对很难抗拒那种结论，不是吗？完全是因为它沉没的那一刻，人们以各种方式被这个故事所触动，通常是以相当疯狂的方式，因为有些人声称他们在船上失去了亲戚，而他们根本没有，所有这些，我的意思是，是的，你见过这个人
joseph marrington of philadelphia what a baroque story he has yeah he keeps a vigil for two days he said i'm looking for information about my friend uh william lambert of greensboro pennsylvania he was my closest friend on earth as dear to me as a brother. He saved my life several years ago in the jungles of Ecuador when we were searching for rubber. Well, unless, of course, he'd won a ticket in a card game in Southampton at the last minute. Oh, right. It's like, yeah. I mean, you never know. You never know.
费城的约瑟夫·马林顿，他有一个多么巴洛克式的故事。是的，他守夜了两天，他说我正在寻找关于我的朋友，宾夕法尼亚州格林斯伯勒的威廉·兰伯特的资料，他是我在地球上最亲密的朋友，像兄弟一样亲。几年前，当我们在厄瓜多尔的丛林中寻找橡胶时，他救了我的命。好吧，除非，当然，他在最后一刻在南安普敦的纸牌游戏中赢了一张票。哦，对。就像，是的。我的意思是，你永远不知道。你永远不知道。
But this boat, Marianton, just to be clear, this person he's looking for doesn't exist. I know. He's never been to Ecuador looking for rubber. It's just all a mad fantasy. And that obviously happens all the time with disasters and things, doesn't it? Yeah, it does. And of course, the other thing that happens in disasters is that people look around for someone to blame. Yeah.
但这条船，马林顿，为了清楚起见，他正在寻找的这个人并不存在。我知道。他从来没有去过厄瓜多尔寻找橡胶。这只是一个疯狂的幻想。这显然在灾难和事情中一直发生，不是吗？是的，确实。当然，灾难中发生的另一件事是人们四处寻找替罪羊。是的。
So, Captain Smith. Blameless. Has gone down with his ship. Blameless, Tom. Be British. Isn't that what he said? So, he's not around. He's dead.
所以，史密斯船长。无可指责。随船沉没了。无可指责，汤姆。做个英国人。他不是这么说的吗？所以，他不在了。他死了。
Yeah. But Bruce Ismay is alive. So he's the guy in charge of the whole shebang. And in a terrible state, it's fair to say, isn't it, Tom? I mean, he's sitting in that cabin shaking. Saying he should have gone down with the ship. Yeah. So Jack Thayer, who we've quoted before, visits Ismay in his cabin,
是的。但布鲁斯·伊斯梅还活着。所以他是整个事情的负责人。而且处于一种可怕的状态，可以说，不是吗，汤姆？我的意思是，他坐在那个船舱里发抖。说他应该随船沉没。是的。所以杰克·塞耶，我们之前引用过他，去船舱里看望了伊斯梅，
found him seated in his pyjamas on his bunk, staring straight ahead, shaking like a leaf. Thayer says to him, you did the right thing. Yeah. You should have got on that boat. And Ismay was always grateful to the Thayers for that and corresponded with Thayer's widowed mother for many years to come after that. But obviously Ismay has, it's a terrible blow to his professional reputation. It's also a terrible blow to his professional reputation. It's also a terrible blow to his
发现他穿着睡衣坐在铺位上，直视前方，像一片叶子一样发抖。塞耶对他说，你做了正确的事。是的。你应该上那艘船。伊斯梅一直很感激塞耶一家，并在那之后与塞耶的遗孀保持了多年的通信。但显然伊斯梅，这对他的职业声誉是一个沉重的打击。这对他的职业声誉也是一个沉重的打击。这也是一个沉重的打击
moral reputation. And on top of that, I mean, he knows that it's a terrible blow to the reputation and financial standing of the company that he's responsible for. Yeah. So in every way, he knows that things are bad, but when he arrives in New York, it's a shock to him, I think, to find out just how bad it is. Oh, he becomes public enemy number one, doesn't he? He is accused of being a coward. There are all the stories that he insisted that they break the speed records. Yeah, which we've already said before is not true.
道德声誉。最重要的是，我的意思是，他知道这对公司负责的声誉和财务状况是一个沉重的打击。是的。所以从各方面来看，他知道情况很糟糕，但当他到达纽约时，我想他发现情况有多糟糕对他来说是一个打击。哦，他成了头号公敌，不是吗？他被指控为懦夫。有所有的故事说他坚持要打破速度记录。是的，我们之前已经说过那不是真的。
Which you will see in the film. Yeah. So the picture of Ismay that you see in the James Cameron film is pretty much the picture that was presented to Americans, particularly in 1912, 1913, that he is the author of his own misfortunes, that he has effectively killed all these people, that he is such a weasel that he wouldn't stay there like a man. I don't think there's been a single film or TV series where he's not a weasel. So the Julian Fellows one as well, the TV series, he's even worse in that one.
你会在电影中看到。是的。所以你在詹姆斯·卡梅隆电影中看到的伊斯梅的形象，几乎就是1912年、1913年呈现给美国人的形象，即他是自己不幸的始作俑者，他实际上杀死了所有这些人，他是一个如此卑鄙的人，以至于他不像个男人那样留在那里。我不认为有哪一部电影或电视剧里他不是个卑鄙小人。所以朱利安·费罗斯的那一部也是，电视剧，他在那一部里更糟糕。
And the fact that he is British in New York, obviously turbocharges it as well. Meanwhile, back in Britain, as you said, the attitude is kind of hurrah. We've come tremendously well out of the sinking of our largest ship, isn't it? It's very weird. Lord Beecham, a cabinet minister. In all our minds, there has been a thrill at the heroism and self-sacrifice. They were ordinary communal garden members
而且他在纽约是英国人这一事实，显然也加剧了这一点。与此同时，回到英国，正如你所说，态度是一种欢呼。我们从我们最大船只的沉没中表现得非常出色，不是吗？这很奇怪。比彻姆勋爵，一位内阁大臣。在我们所有人的心中，有一种英雄主义和自我牺牲的快感。他们是盎格鲁-撒克逊种族的普通成员
of the Anglo-Saxon race. It makes one proud to think that there were so many men ready to face death quietly and in a self-sacrificing spirit, making way for the women and children. And then he says, unbelievably, not only does it make us proud of our race,
。想到有这么多男人准备安静地面对死亡，并以自我牺牲的精神，为妇女和儿童让路，这让人感到自豪。然后他说，令人难以置信的是，这不仅让我们为我们的种族感到自豪，
it makes us sure there is a great destiny reserved in the world still for the Anglo-Saxon race. Well, and he's not unusual in saying that. I mean, there's a lot of commentary in the press comparing Anglo-Saxon sang-froid with the excitable gibberings of lesser breeds. I know. That's absolutely. They say, all the newspapers say, well, thank goodness the people on the ship weren't Italian or Chinese. It would have been a very different story. Yeah, yeah.
它让我们确信，世界上仍然为盎格鲁-撒克逊种族保留着伟大的命运。好吧，他在说这一点时并不罕见。我的意思是，媒体上有很多评论将盎格鲁-撒克逊人的冷静与劣等种族的兴奋胡言乱语进行比较。我知道。那是绝对的。他们说，所有的报纸都说，谢天谢地，船上的人不是意大利人或中国人。那将是一个非常不同的故事。是的，是的。
And so it's basically a tremendous success. As Richard Davenport Hines says, basically it takes its place alongside the defeat of the Spanish Armada. And Nelson's victory at Trafalgar is a great British naval triumph. Well, you've said how Lightoller, the most senior officer to survive,
所以这基本上是一个巨大的成功。正如理查德·达文波特·海恩斯所说，基本上它与击败西班牙无敌舰队并列。纳尔逊在特拉法加的胜利是一场伟大的英国海军胜利。好吧，你已经说过幸存的最高级军官莱托勒，
goes on to take part in the Dunkirk evacuation. Yeah, which is, of course, a defeat. I mean, I suppose it's a kind of disaster that gets transmuted into a success. I think so. Yes. I mean, obviously, people have often said this about the British Empire, haven't they? That there was a strange sort of reverse alchemy at work in British imperial fantasies, perhaps born out of anxiety, conscience, who knows, where people loved heroic failures. I mean, General Gordon, our episodes about General Gordon, the retreat from Kabul, this is one of those. Right. But the emphasis has to be on heroic. Yes. So hence all the transmutation of things that actually happened into myth very early on.
后来参加了敦刻尔克大撤退。是的，这当然是一场失败。我的意思是，我想这是一种转化为成功的灾难。我想是的。是的。我的意思是，显然，人们经常这样说大英帝国，不是吗？在英国帝国的幻想中，有一种奇怪的逆向炼金术在起作用，也许源于焦虑、良心，谁知道呢，人们喜欢英雄式的失败。我的意思是，戈登将军，我们关于戈登将军的剧集，从喀布尔撤退，这就是其中之一。对。但重点必须是英雄式的。是的。所以，因此，所有实际上发生的事情在很早的时候就被转化为神话。
So the band playing on and the women and children first and Captain Smith, be British, all that kind of thing. You see, they make gigantic sand models on Bournemouth Beach. Britannia mourns, Captain Smith at baby. Yeah. Women and children first. To the Heroes of the Titanic. These are the names of these great sand sculptures that are made in the following weeks. And there is a kind of sense of sort of morbid, sentimental celebration. Yeah.
所以乐队继续演奏，妇女和儿童优先，史密斯船长，做个英国人，所有这些事情。你看，他们在伯恩茅斯海滩上制作了巨大的沙雕模型。不列颠哀悼，史密斯船长在婴儿身边。是的。妇女和儿童优先。致泰坦尼克号的英雄们。这些是接下来的几周里制作的这些伟大沙雕的名字。有一种病态的、感伤的庆祝感。是的。
Which again, I mean, we've looked at Ismay's reputation in America. I mean, this is terrible for him in Britain as well, because he has brought shame on Britain by getting into the boat in his slippers. By not dying, yes. As, of course, has Duff Cooper as well. Yeah. So the pair of them are seen to have failed the British race. Yes, exactly.
这再次，我的意思是，我们看了伊斯梅在美国的声誉。我的意思是，这对他在英国也是可怕的，因为他穿着拖鞋上了救生艇，给英国带来了耻辱。通过没有死，是的。当然，达夫·库珀也是如此。是的。所以他们两人被视为辜负了英国种族。是的，没错。
So there's a big memorial service, isn't there, on the 19th of April in London at St. Paul's. Thousands of people go and actually have to be turned away. I mean, it sounds very moving. There are people fainting. The music is kind of Rock of Ages, Eternal Father, Strong to Save, all the kind of classic kind of nautical hymns. But already, Dominic, people are starting to project quite profoundly moral metaphors onto it. So in your notes, you've got the heading, Woke Bishop.
所以有一个大型追悼会，不是吗，4月19日在伦敦的圣保罗大教堂。成千上万的人去了，实际上不得不被拒之门外。我的意思是，这听起来非常动人。有人晕倒了。音乐是《万古磐石》、《永恒之父，拯救之强》，所有经典的航海赞美诗。但多米尼克，人们已经开始将深刻的道德隐喻投射到它上面。所以，在你的笔记中，你有一个标题，觉醒的主教。
I feared you would read that out. And this Woke Bishop is specifically Edward Talbot, the Bishop of Winchester. And he goes to Southampton, you know, the place where so many people have died on the 21st of April. And he gets into this thing that will be very, very popular. In fact, it's still popular to this day. The idea that it is an emblem of hubris. He believed God meant that the cruel and wanton waste of money, which was needed on every hand for the help of the needy, that this is a rebuke, the sinking of the ship with all its furnishings and fittings, that this is a sign of God's the sinking of the ship with all its furnishings and fittings, that this is a sign of God's anger with the wealth and pride and arrogance that the Titanic he sees as representing. And that is something I think that has been a kind of enduring concept, isn't it?
我担心你会读出来。这位觉醒的主教是爱德华·塔尔博特，温彻斯特主教。他在4月21日去了南安普敦，你知道，那个有那么多人死亡的地方。他陷入了这种将非常、非常流行的东西。事实上，它至今仍然很流行。它是一个傲慢的象征的想法。他相信上帝的意思是，那些本应用于帮助穷人的残酷和肆意的金钱浪费，这是一种谴责，船连同其所有的陈设和配件的沉没，这是一种上帝对泰坦尼克号所代表的财富、骄傲和傲慢的愤怒的迹象。我认为这是一种持久的概念，不是吗？
Oh, definitely, definitely. For our Restless History subscribers, we did a recent live stream about disasters in history, didn't we? Going all the way back to Sodom and Gomorrah. And the idea, disasters, I think, either stand for themselves, nothing but themselves, or they often come to stand for a sort of a critique of hubris, of political extravagance, of inequality, negligence, all these kinds of things. And right away, Titanic is that with knobs on. And what's fascinating about it is that because Americans and British
哦，绝对，绝对。对于我们的《历史的余味》订阅者，我们最近做了一个关于历史灾难的直播，不是吗？一直追溯到所多玛和蛾摩拉。我认为，灾难要么代表它们自己，除了它们自己什么都不是，要么它们经常成为一种对傲慢、政治奢侈、不平等、疏忽等各种事情的批判。而泰坦尼克号立刻就是那种带有旋钮的东西。令人着迷的是，因为美国人和英国人
are both implicated in it pretty much equally, therefore the perspective that is cast on the disaster on either side of the Atlantic is very kind of revelatory about broader political and cultural attitudes. Yeah, because in America, a Senate subcommittee is set up under William Alden Smith, Republican Senator from Michigan. And this is a great age of populism in the United States. And it is an exercise in pure populism.
都几乎同样卷入其中，因此大西洋两岸对灾难的看法非常揭示了更广泛的政治和文化态度。是的，因为在美国，参议院小组委员会是在密歇根州共和党参议员威廉·奥尔登·史密斯的领导下成立的。这是美国民粹主义的伟大时代。这是一次纯粹的民粹主义演习。
The evils of big business, the evils of plutocracy, British aristocrats in particular. Richard Davenport Hines, who i think it's fair to say writes his book titanic lies very much as a dark comedy yes he's very uh scathing about william walton smith he was all rush and humbug he says prone to sum up situations on scant facts he hunted clues to ismay's accomplices with all the salivating doggedness and random sideways lunges of a young Basset hound tracking hares. The most famous exchange where he asks the witness, what was the iceberg made of? The reply is ice, I suppose, which kind of sums up the level of the investigation.
大企业的罪恶，财阀政治的罪恶，特别是英国贵族。理查德·达文波特·海恩斯，我认为公平地说，他写他的书《泰坦尼克号的谎言》非常像一部黑色喜剧，是的，他对威廉·奥尔登·史密斯非常尖刻，他说他全是匆忙和骗局，倾向于根据贫乏的事实总结情况，他以一只年轻巴塞特猎犬追踪野兔时那种流着口水的执着和随机的侧向猛扑，寻找伊斯梅同伙的线索。最著名的交流是他问证人，冰山是由什么制成的？回答是冰，我想，这总结了调查的水平。
However, we must not pat ourselves on the backs, must we? Really? What? Well, so the British report on the disaster, by contrast, censure so light it sounded like applause. Well, the British report, actually, I think it's fair to say the British report does go very easy on White Star, on Captain Smith in particular, on the officers. But actually, its findings are pretty much right aren't they being substantiated haven't they yeah it says you know they neglected the ice warnings they should have reduced speed they weren't however going faster than any other ship would have been going
然而，我们不能拍拍自己的背，不是吗？真的吗？什么？好吧，所以英国关于灾难的报告，相比之下，谴责如此轻微，听起来像掌声。好吧，英国的报告，实际上，我认为公平地说，英国的报告确实对白星航运公司，特别是对史密斯船长，对军官们非常宽容。但实际上，它的发现几乎是正确的，不是吗，它们被证实了，不是吗？是的，它说你知道，他们忽视了冰警告，他们应该减速，然而他们并没有比任何其他船只行驶得更快
they definitely weren't going because ismay had told no smith to get to new york early so that's absolutely definitively debunked. Yeah, that inquiry, which is Lord Mersey, I think it correctly identifies all the things that went wrong. Not enough light boats, not a proper procedure, all that stuff. But it says, I think fairly, this is not unusual culpability and negligence on the part of White Star or the crew. What they are doing is standard practice throughout the industry, as it were. And that is the issue. Rather than individual fault, the issue is the general culture and the fact that effectively, this was going to happen. It's incredibly bad luck that it's happened to
他们绝对不是因为伊斯梅告诉史密斯早点到达纽约，所以这绝对被揭穿了。是的，那次调查，是默西勋爵，我认为它正确地指出了所有出错的事情。救生艇不够，没有适当的程序，所有这些东西。但它说，我认为公平地说，这不是白星航运公司或船员的异常罪责和疏忽。他们所做的是整个行业的标准做法，正如他们所说。这就是问题所在。与其说是个人过错，不如说是普遍的文化，事实上，这实际上是要发生的。泰坦尼克号发生这种事是非常不幸的，但显然在某个时候，如果它没有发生在泰坦尼克号上，它也会发生在别人身上，特别是那个问题，没有足够的救生艇。我的意思是，那太疯狂了。是的。所以从中吸取了教训，不是吗？并引入了新的法规。因此，船只必须携带足够的救生艇供所有乘客和船员使用，这成为了一种义务。海员必须接受培训来操作它们。引入了各种法规。他们建立了一个国际冰巡逻队来监测冰山。航运航线被移到了冰层覆盖的海域以南。但认为这只是一次发生的事故，认为它总是会发生，人们对那个结论并不满意。我认为公平地说。
Titanic, but it was clearly at some point, if it hadn't happened to Titanic, it would have happened to somebody else, especially that issue, not having enough lifeboats. I mean, that's bonkers. Yeah. And so lessons are drawn from that, aren't they? And new regulations brought in. And so it becomes an obligation on ships to carry enough lifeboats for all passengers and crew. Seamen have to be trained to handle them. All kinds of regulations are brought in. They set up an international ice patrol to monitor icebergs. The shipping lanes are moved south of the ice-encumbered seas. But the idea that it was just an accident that happened, that it was always going to happen, people are not content with that conclusion. I think it's fair to say.
不，不，不。他们想要意义，不是吗？他们渴望意义。所以我认为我们应该在这一点上休息一下。当我们回来时，让我们在这一系列关于泰坦尼克号的最后一集中看看对它的理解是如何在几十年中演变的，以及这个故事被讲述和重述的方式。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《娱乐的余味》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你它是如何运作的。
No, no, no. They want meaning, don't they? They crave meaning. So I think we should take a break at this point. And when we come back, let's have a look in the last segment of this series that we've been doing on Titanic to look at how the understanding of it has evolved over the decades and the way that the story has been told and retold. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。他们说我乘船逃走了，并在调查中羞辱了我，我告诉你，那天晚上我沉得和任何英雄一样深，当我坐在黑暗的水面上发抖时，我冻成了冰，听到我昂贵的生命在婴儿车、钢琴、餐具柜、绞车、锅炉爆炸和破碎的拉格泰姆音乐的混乱中轰然倒下。现在我躲在海后的一所孤独的房子里，潮水静静地把破碎的玩具和帽盒留在我的门口。四月的阵雨，五月的花朵对我来说毫无意义，晚光也一样
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. They said I got away in a boat and humbled me at the inquiry i tell you i sank as far that night as any hero as i sat shivering on the dark water i turned to ice to hear my costly life go thundering down in a pandemonium of prams pian pianos, sideboards, winches, boilers bursting and shredded ragtime. Now I hide in a lonely house behind the sea, where the tide leaves broken toys and hat boxes silently at my door. The showers of April, flowers of May mean nothing to me, nor the late light of
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果您想收听无广告内容、获取额外剧集并优先购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。他们说我乘船逃脱了，并在调查中让我蒙羞。我告诉你们，那天晚上我像任何英雄一样沉沦，当我坐在黑暗的水面上瑟瑟发抖时，我感到心如死灰，听着我那昂贵的生命在婴儿车、钢琴、餐具柜、绞车、锅炉爆炸和破碎的拉格泰姆音乐的混乱声中轰然沉没。现在我躲在海边一栋孤独的房子里，潮水默默地将破碎的玩具和帽盒留在我的门前。四月的阵雨、五月的鲜花对我来说毫无意义，那迟来的光芒也一样。
June, when my gardener describes to strangers how the old man stays in bed on seaward mornings after nights of wind takes his cocaine and will see no one then it is i drown again with all those dim lost faces i never understood my poor soul screams out in the starlight heart breaks loose and rolls down like a stone include me in your lamentations that's uh derek mahon wonderful poem after the titanic ventriloquizing bruises may who is essentially left a broken man by the aftermath of the titanic and ends up a retiree on the irish coast and he really is the archetype of one of those survivors of the Titanic, you know, whose survival is a kind of form of death. So he's publicly humiliated. He is criticized as a coward on both sides of the Atlantic. So Ben Hecht, at this point as a journalist, will go on to become
六月，当我的园丁向陌生人描述那个老人在风雨之夜后的海边清晨如何躺在床上，服用他的可卡因，不见任何人时，我又一次淹没在那些我从未理解的模糊而迷失的面孔中，我可怜的灵魂在星光下尖叫，心碎裂开来，像石头一样滚落，把我写进你的哀歌里吧，那是德里克·马洪的一首精彩的诗，关于泰坦尼克号，借用伊斯梅的口吻，他本质上是一个在泰坦尼克号灾难后彻底崩溃的人，最终在爱尔兰海岸过着退休生活，他确实是泰坦尼克号幸存者的原型，你知道，那种幸存本身就是一种死亡。所以他受到了公开羞辱。他在大西洋两岸都被批评为懦夫。所以本·赫克特，当时作为一名记者，后来成为了
a very distinguished screenwriter, writes the screenplays for Scarface and Notorious and other kind of big films. He writes a poem comparing your hero, Captain Smith, Dominic and Ismay. To hold your place in the ghastly face of death on the sea at night is a seaman's job, but to flee with the mob is an owner's noble right. See, I think that's too harsh, Tom. I think that's much too harsh. It is too harsh. And Lord Mersey's inquiry would agree with you that actually, you know, he was cleared. We quoted in the previous episode that if he had not gotten to the boat when he was given the chance, he would have been dead. And what's the point? Yeah. But he, you know, he goes into a deep depression, partly, I'm sure, because of the public obloquy. But also, you know, he's lost this ship. Everything he is was invested in that ship and it's gone. And not least because he inherited the business. From his father.
一位非常杰出的编剧，为《疤面煞星》、《美人计》和其他一些大片撰写剧本。他写了一首诗，将你的英雄史密斯船长、多米尼克和伊斯梅进行了对比。在夜晚海上的死亡阴影中坚守岗位是海员的职责，但与暴民一起逃跑却是船主的崇高权利。你看，我觉得这太苛刻了，汤姆。我觉得这太苛刻了。确实太苛刻了。默西勋爵的调查会同意你的观点，实际上，你知道，他被洗清了嫌疑。我们在上一集引用过，如果他当时有机会却没有上救生艇，他早就死了。那又有什么意义呢？是的。但他，你知道，他陷入了深深的抑郁，我敢肯定，部分原因是公众的指责。但还有，你知道，他失去了这艘船。他的一切都投入到了那艘船上，而它消失了。而且不仅如此，因为他继承了家族生意。从他父亲那里。
Exactly. Yeah. So a year or so on from the sinking of the Titanic in June 1913, he has stood down from the chairmanship of White Star, effectively retires. He arranges a kind of life of organised routine. He goes golfing in Scotland. As I said, he spends his summers on the coast of Ireland and he never talks about it. And no one in his family ever and they are aware of a kind of silence that prevails over the house. It's not just that he's not talking about the Titanic. He's basically not talking about anything. And there is an occasion where one of his grandchildren asks him, you know, have you ever been in a shipwreck? And there's a kind of very long, embarrassed silence. And then there's another one who's been reading a newspaper and is very proud of his ability to read newspaper and tells Ismay that he had read in the newspaper how there'd been a train crash and 256 people had died. And Ismay retorts to this, how do you know 256 people died? Were you there? Did you count them? So that sense that in his mind, he's going over and over again. So he dies in 1937, gets buried in Putney Vale Cemetery. And on his tomb, there are carvings of ships.
没错。是的。所以泰坦尼克号沉没一年多后，1913年6月，他辞去了白星航运公司董事长的职务，实际上退休了。他安排了一种有规律的生活。他在苏格兰打高尔夫球。正如我所说，他在爱尔兰海岸度过夏天，他从不谈论这件事。他的家人也从不谈论，他们能感觉到笼罩在房子上的一种沉默。不仅仅是他不谈论泰坦尼克号。他基本上什么都不谈。有一次，他的一个孙子问他，你知道，你曾经经历过海难吗？然后是一阵非常漫长、尴尬的沉默。后来还有另一个孙子，他一直在看报纸，对自己的阅读能力非常自豪，告诉伊斯梅他在报纸上读到了一起火车事故，有256人死亡。伊斯梅反驳道，你怎么知道死了256人？你在现场吗？你数过他们吗？所以那种感觉，在他的脑海里，他一遍又一遍地重温。所以他在1937年去世，被安葬在普特尼谷公墓。在他的墓碑上，有船的雕刻。
And there is a biblical quote from James 3, 4. Behold also the ships, which though they be so great and are driven of fierce winds, yet are turned about with a very small helm whithersoever the governor listeth which is i mean kind of tragic which though they be so great so tom you know that poem that you were reading that is a wonderful poem the derrick mann poem guess where his father and his grandfather worked uh in titanic they worked at harland and wolf did they yeah so you can see why he would be drawn i think that poem lots of people do that poem In the Titanic? They worked at Harland and Wolfe. Did they? Yeah. So you can see why he would be drawn. I think that poem, lots of people do that poem in the equivalent of A-levels in Ireland,
还有一句来自《雅各书》3章4节的圣经引文。看哪，船只虽然甚大，又被大风催逼，只用小小的舵，就随着掌舵的意思转动，这真是，我的意思是，有点悲剧色彩，虽然它们如此巨大，所以汤姆，你知道你读的那首诗，那是一首精彩的诗，德里克·马洪的诗，猜猜他的父亲和祖父在哪里工作，在泰坦尼克号，他们在哈兰德与沃尔夫造船厂工作，是吗？是的，所以你可以看出为什么他会被吸引，我想那首诗，很多人在泰坦尼克号上做那首诗？他们在哈兰德与沃尔夫工作。是吗？是的。所以你可以看出为什么他会被吸引。我想那首诗，很多人在爱尔兰的A-level考试中做那首诗，
Leaving Cert. It's like a standard text that they do. It's very powerful. Just before we move on, though, from Ismay and the mood that is articulated in that poem of a kind of living death, there is another figure who suffers similar obloquy, and this is Masabumi Hosono, who we mentioned as traveling on second class, the Japanese civil servant who'd been in Russia studying the Russian railway system and is going back to Japan via the Atlantic. And he reminisces about the sinking. He says that he is standing on the deck thinking how he would never see his wife
毕业证书考试。这就像他们学习的标准文本。它非常有力量。不过，在我们离开伊斯梅和那首诗中所表达的那种活死人的情绪之前，还有另一个人遭受了类似的指责，这就是我们提到的二等舱乘客细野正文，那位曾在俄罗斯研究俄罗斯铁路系统的日本公务员，正经由大西洋返回日本。他回忆起沉船事件。他说他站在甲板上，想着他再也见不到他的妻子
and children again, but determined to behave like a Japanese gentleman. So he says, I tried to prepare myself for the last moment with no agitation, making up my mind not to leave anything disgraceful as a Japanese subject. But he is then called by a sailor to get into lifeboat 13, exactly as Ismay was. Essentially, you you know there is a spare place there are no women and children if you don't take it you will die pointlessly and so he gets in and he survives and he gets to new york and he crosses america and he goes back to japan and there he is ostracized he loses his job oh my word but because he's basically i mean he's the only person in j who knows about Russian railway.
和孩子了，但决心表现得像个日本绅士。所以他说，我试图让自己在最后一刻保持冷静，下定决心不留下任何作为日本臣民的耻辱。但他随后被一名水手叫去登上13号救生艇，正如伊斯梅一样。本质上，你知道那里有一个空位，没有妇女和儿童，如果你不坐上去，你就会毫无意义地死去，所以他上去了，他幸存了下来，他到了纽约，穿过美国，回到了日本，在那里他被排斥，他失去了工作，天哪，但因为他基本上，我的意思是，他是日本唯一了解俄罗斯铁路的人。
So they ultimately, they give it back to him. But his, his family are humiliated and ashamed for decades and decades. And what's fascinating about this. So I kind of vaguely knew of this story and had always assumed that it was a Japanese expression of, you know, of morality,
所以他们最终还是让他复职了。但他的家人几十年来一直感到羞辱和耻辱。最令人着迷的是这一点。所以我隐约知道这个故事，一直以为这是日本的一种道德表达，
of public shame, all that kind of thing. But apparently not. So Margaret Mell, who's a German historian of 20th century Japan, she says, Hasono's failure to act as the Anglo-Saxon nations evidently expected their men to act caused embarrassment in Japan, but more because of the Japanese's acceptance of Western values than because of their own traditions. So that's kind of fascinating. Oh, so it's not because that's what a Japanese person should do. That's what a Japanese person should do if we're imitating the Anglo-Saxons, basically.
公众羞耻，诸如此类。但显然不是。所以玛格丽特·梅尔，一位研究20世纪日本的德国历史学家，她说，细野未能按照盎格鲁-撒克逊国家显然期望其男性采取的行动行事，在日本引起了尴尬，但更多是因为日本人对西方价值观的接受，而不是因为他们自己的传统。所以这很有趣。哦，所以不是因为那是日本人应该做的。如果我们在模仿盎格鲁-撒克逊人，那才是日本人应该做的，基本上。
Yeah. They're condemning him in the way that the Anglo-Saxon powers are condemning Ismay. So fascinating. Right. It's interesting. I mean, the one thing that comes out of what happens afterwards is how many of the survivors are utterly traumatized by survivor's guilt. Yeah. So it's not just the traumatic experience, but for so many people, they are thinking afterwards, why did I live when so many died? Why did I live when my husband died? So Charlotte Collier, we started one of the episodes, didn't we, with the story of her and her husband the grocer from Hampshire and she has basically been forced into a boat against her will her husband dies
是的。他们谴责他的方式与盎格鲁-撒克逊大国谴责伊斯梅的方式一样。太迷人了。对。这很有趣。我的意思是，事后发生的一件事是，有多少幸存者因幸存者内疚而受到彻底的创伤。是的。所以不仅仅是创伤性的经历，对许多人来说，他们事后都在想，为什么当那么多人死去时我却活着？为什么当我的丈夫死去时我却活着？所以夏洛特·科利尔，我们开始其中一集时，不是吗，讲了她和她丈夫，那个来自汉普郡的杂货商的故事，她基本上是被迫违背意愿上了救生艇，她的丈夫死了
she dies two years later and she never ever recovers yeah Richard Davenport Hines has a list of people who take their own lives in the years or the decades afterwards. So we've quoted a few times Jack Thayer, who was then a boy, wasn't he? He goes on to become a Philadelphia banker. He kills himself in 1945. The lookout, Frederick Fleet, he killed himself in 1965. It's remarkable. I mean, maybe, you know, if you were being very cynical, you would say, well, statistically, there would be a number of suicides, but it is remarkable how many there are. And I think there is a pattern. So particularly women who have children, who lose their husbands, seem to have been particularly traumatized and devastated. So another example, you mentioned Charlotte Collier. Another example is Juliette Laroche, who is the French wife of Joseph Laroche, the Haitian. Yeah. The guy from the Caribbean. Yeah.
她两年后去世，她从未恢复过来。是的，理查德·达文波特-海恩斯有一份名单，列出了在随后的几年或几十年里自杀的人。所以我们引用了几次杰克·塞耶，他当时还是个男孩，不是吗？他后来成为了一名费城银行家。他在1945年自杀。瞭望员弗雷德里克·弗利特，他在1965年自杀。这很了不起。我的意思是，也许，你知道，如果你非常愤世嫉俗，你会说，嗯，从统计学上讲，会有一定数量的自杀，但令人惊讶的是数量如此之多。而且我认为有一个模式。所以特别是那些有孩子、失去丈夫的女性，似乎受到了特别严重的创伤和打击。所以另一个例子，你提到了夏洛特·科利尔。另一个例子是朱丽叶·拉罗什，她是海地人约瑟夫·拉罗什的法国妻子。是的。那个来自加勒比海的家伙。是的。
So he has been left and her and her two daughters have gone on the boat. They arrive in New York. They do not go on to Haiti because he's dead. They don't have any reason to go there. She doesn't speak any English, so she can't make sense of what's going on in New York. So she goes back to France and she of course was pregnant. And when she gets back to France, she delivers a boy and calls him Joseph. But she apparently never mentions her husband again. She never talks about her experience on that night. And she micromanages the lives of her daughters, never letting them out of her sight. And there is a photo of her with her husband and the two daughters just before they set out. And the younger daughter, who was only two at the time, very small, but the three-year-old girl, her face is kind of ablaze with happiness and joy. And it's like, it cuts through you like a knife
所以他被留下了，她和她的两个女儿上了船。她们到达纽约。她们没有去海地，因为他死了。她们没有任何理由去那里。她不会说英语，所以她无法理解纽约发生了什么。所以她回到了法国，她当然怀孕了。当她回到法国时，她生下了一个男孩，给他取名约瑟夫。但她显然再也没有提到过她的丈夫。她从未谈论过她在那晚的经历。她事无巨细地管理着女儿们的生活，从不让她们离开她的视线。有一张她和她丈夫以及两个女儿在出发前的照片。那个当时只有两岁的小女儿，非常小，但那个三岁的小女孩，她的脸上闪烁着幸福和快乐。这就像，它像刀子一样穿过你
through your heart to see that photograph and know what is coming. And it's like, it cuts through you like a knife through your heart to see that photograph and know what is coming. And amazingly, the youngest of those daughters lives until 1998. So that's a year after the James Cameron films come out. She's still alive. I mean, it's amazing. And I think you do have the sense there that all of these people are characters in a story that they don't really control anymore because their fates, whether they die or survive, are objects of such passionate public curiosity that the story that they are part of is no longer theirs. So amazingly, the first film about the Titanic, it's called Saved from Titanic, appears four weeks after the Titanic's gone down. So in May 1912. And the star was on the Titanic.
穿过你的心，看到那张照片，知道即将发生什么。这就像，它像刀子一样穿过你的心，看到那张照片，知道即将发生什么。令人惊讶的是，这些女儿中最小的一个一直活到1998年。所以那是詹姆斯·卡梅隆的电影上映一年后。她还活着。我的意思是，这太神奇了。而且我认为你确实有这种感觉，所有这些人都是他们不再真正控制的故事中的角色，因为他们的命运，无论是死是活，都是如此激烈的公众好奇心的对象，以至于他们所参与的故事不再属于他们了。所以令人惊讶的是，关于泰坦尼克号的第一部电影，叫《泰坦尼克号上的幸存者》，在泰坦尼克号沉没四周后就出现了。所以是在1912年5月。而主演就在泰坦尼克号上。
Yes. Unbelievable. And she plays herself in the dress that she had worn in her lifeboat. Dorothy Gibson. I mean, that is mind boggling, isn't it? That within four weeks, she's reenacting it for the cameras presumably profiting from it so the walter lord book the very famous book a night to remember which has became the definitive account probably for the best part of 50 years really didn't it and that was based on survivors letters and things
是的。难以置信。她穿着她在救生艇上穿的那件衣服扮演她自己。多萝西·吉布森。我的意思是，这太令人震惊了，不是吗？在四周之内，她就在为摄像机重演它，大概还从中获利，所以沃尔特·洛德的那本书，那本非常有名的书《永不沉没》，它在过去50年里大概一直是权威的叙述，不是吗，那是基于幸存者的信件和东西
wasn't it he interviewed lots of survivors interestingly, he didn't take any notes. He just said he remembered what they had said and wrote it down. And I mean, let's get to it, Tom, because you've been itching to talk about the James Cameron film. Well, so, I mean, this is the great cinematic analysis of it, the great cinematic retelling of the story. It's the one that kind of looms over the popular understanding of the entire narrative. So let's just stick with Ismay, who we've been talking about. We've said how he always gets represented as an absolute rotter. And he's one of the few purely contemptible figures in the film. He's awful in the film, isn't he? He is. So even Cal, the sinisterly camp. Yeah, he's Billy Zane, isn't he? Billy Zy zane i mean he has kind of redeeming moments he tries to save rose but ismay is hopeless so he is shown as
不是吗？他采访了许多幸存者，有趣的是，他没有做任何笔记。他只是说他记得他们说过的话并写了下来。我的意思是，让我们谈谈吧，汤姆，因为你一直渴望谈论詹姆斯·卡梅隆的电影。好吧，所以，我的意思是，这是对它的伟大电影分析，对这个故事的伟大电影重述。它是那种笼罩在对整个叙事的大众理解之上的电影。所以让我们坚持谈谈伊斯梅，我们一直在谈论他。我们说过他总是被描绘成一个绝对的坏蛋。他是电影中少数几个纯粹令人鄙视的人物之一。他在电影里很糟糕，不是吗？他是。所以即使是卡尔，那个阴险的娘娘腔。是的，他是比利·赞恩，不是吗？比利·赞恩，我的意思是，他有某种救赎时刻，他试图拯救露丝，但伊斯梅是无可救药的，所以他被展示为
urging the titanic on faster and faster and there's um a kind of classic exchange where they're all at table and leonardo caprio's character is there as well. And Molly Brown, you know, who's a real figure, played by Kathy Bates in the film. Unsinkable. Yeah. Says to Ismay, hey, who thought of the name Titanic? Was it you, Bruce? And Ismay says, yes, actually, I wanted to convey sheer size.
敦促泰坦尼克号越来越快，有一个经典的交流，他们都在餐桌旁，莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥的角色也在那里。莫莉·布朗，你知道，那是一个真实的人物，在电影中由凯西·贝茨扮演。永不沉没。是的。对伊斯梅说，嘿，是谁想出的泰坦尼克号这个名字？是你吗，布鲁斯？伊斯梅说，是的，实际上，我想传达纯粹的规模。
And size means stability, luxury, and above all, strength. And that's exactly how people talk, of course. Yes. And then Rose, played by Kate Winslet. Do you know of Dr. Freud, Mr. Ismay? His ideas about the male preoccupation with size might be of particular interest to you. Oh, for God's sake. Yeah.
而规模意味着稳定性、奢华，最重要的是，力量。当然，人们就是这样说话的。是的。然后是露丝，由凯特·温斯莱特扮演。你听说过弗洛伊德医生吗，伊斯梅先生？他关于男性对规模的痴迷的想法可能对你特别感兴趣。哦，看在上帝的份上。是的。
And of course, Ismay has never heard of Freud. Yeah. I mean, there is a lot of Freudian stuff. Famously, when Rose arrives in Southampton and sees the Titanic for the first time, I don't see what all the fuss is about. It doesn't look any bigger than the Mauritania. And then Cal, the Billy Zane character. You can be blasé about some things, Rose, but not about Titanic. It's over 100 feet longer than the Mauritania and far more luxurious. And this whole thing about how proud everyone is that Titanic is three inches longer than the Olympic. And that sense that the Titanic is size. I mean, its size really matters throughout every retelling of the story. And it matters to the making of the film. It's the fact that the film is shot on a Titanic scale, that they have to build an entire new studio lot to film it in mexico in
当然，伊斯梅从未听说过弗洛伊德。我的意思是，有很多弗洛伊德的东西。众所周知，当露丝到达南安普敦第一次看到泰坦尼克号时，我不明白有什么大惊小怪的。它看起来并不比毛里塔尼亚号大。然后是卡尔，那个比利·赞恩的角色。你可以对某些事情表现得冷漠，露丝，但不能对泰坦尼克号。它比毛里塔尼亚号长100多英尺，而且豪华得多。关于每个人都为泰坦尼克号比奥林匹克号长三英寸而感到自豪的整件事。那种泰坦尼克号就是规模的感觉。我的意思是，规模在故事的每一次重述中确实都很重要。它对电影的制作也很重要。事实是，这部电影是以泰坦尼克号的规模拍摄的，他们必须在墨西哥建造一个全新的摄影棚来拍摄它，在
mexico yeah and we've been talking throughout how the sea was very very calm on the night of the sinking and this is very very useful for james because it meant that he could film the whole thing with kind of water all around they build build this enormous, enormous ship. And the tank that contains it, I mean, it has 17 million gallons of water. All the fittings are done with immense precision. You know, all the upholstery, the furniture, the fittings, the plates, they're all kind of stamped with the requisite logos.
墨西哥，是的，我们一直在谈论沉船当晚海面非常非常平静，这对詹姆斯来说非常非常有用，因为这意味着他可以拍摄整个过程，周围都是水，他们建造了这艘巨大巨大的船。容纳它的水箱，我的意思是，它有1700万加仑的水。所有的配件都是以极高的精度完成的。你知道，所有的室内装潢、家具、配件、盘子，它们都印有必要的标志。
But at the time, Tom, I can remember when it was being made and then when it came out, the expectation was that the film would prove to Bob to be a crash. Yeah. A kind of reenactment of the Titanic. Yes. That this was a colossal folly because it was the most expensive film of its kind ever made. The James Cameron, who'd obviously famously done Aliens before it, was embarking on this vanity project of something, you know, rather Ismay-like.
但在当时，汤姆，我记得当它正在制作时，然后当它上映时，人们的预期是这部电影会被证明是一场灾难。是的。泰坦尼克号的一种重演。是的。这是一场巨大的愚蠢，因为它是同类电影中最昂贵的。詹姆斯·卡梅隆，他显然在之前很有名地制作了《异形》，正在进行这个虚荣项目，你知道，相当像伊斯梅。
Yeah. Something that had to be bigger and better on a bigger scale and was heading towards the iceberg of critical obloquy. Right. That Nemesis would punish his hubris. Yes. But actually, of course, it's a massive, massive, well, it's a titanic success. Very good. Yeah.
是的。某种必须更大更好、规模更大的东西，正朝着批评指责的冰山驶去。对。命运女神会惩罚他的傲慢。是的。但实际上，当然，这是一个巨大巨大的，好吧，这是一个泰坦尼克式的成功。非常好。是的。
And within a year of its release, it's become the biggest grossing film of all time and actually overtakes Jurassic Park, which is another film freighted with 90s style metaphors. But not everybody liked Titanic, did they? It's regarded as a kind of a sort of nod back to the kind of classic days of Hollywood to some extent, isn't it? Kenneth Turan in the Los Angeles Times. Do you know what he said, Tom? No, what did he say? I know you won't like it because you love Titanic.
在上映一年内，它成为了有史以来票房最高的电影，实际上超过了《侏罗纪公园》，那是另一部充满90年代风格隐喻的电影。但并不是每个人都喜欢《泰坦尼克号》，是吗？它在某种程度上被视为对好莱坞经典时代的一种致敬，不是吗？肯尼斯·图兰在《洛杉矶时报》。你知道他说了什么吗，汤姆？不，他说了什么？我知道你不会喜欢它，因为你喜欢《泰坦尼克号》。
He said, what really brings on the tears in this film is Cameron's insistence that writing this kind of movie is within his abilities. Not only is it not, it's not even close. Well, how many films has he made? Well, okay, you want a filmmaker. Robert Altman, great American filmmaker. Oh, Robert Altman. Who cares about Robert Altman?
他说，这部电影真正让人流泪的是卡梅隆坚持认为编写这种电影在他的能力范围内。不仅不是，甚至连边都沾不上。好吧，他拍了多少部电影？好吧，好吧，你想要一位电影制作人。罗伯特·奥特曼，伟大的美国电影制作人。哦，罗伯特·奥特曼。谁在乎罗伯特·奥特曼？
Has he ever sunk a large ship in a tank in a studio lot in Mexico? I don't think so. The most dreadful piece of work I've ever seen in my entire life, he said of Titanic. I mean, the truth of the matter, Tom, is it's very spectacular, but it's really... Are you ready for this? Yeah. It's basically a film for 15-year-old girls, isn't it? it i mean that's what people say about it okay okay dominic that is what people say about it that is how it is now seen at the time it was not because of course there's the
他曾经在墨西哥的摄影棚里在水箱里沉没过一艘大船吗？我不这么认为。他评价《泰坦尼克号》时说，这是我一生中见过的最可怕的作品。我的意思是，事实是，汤姆，它非常壮观，但它真的……你准备好了吗？是的。它基本上是一部给15岁女孩看的电影，不是吗？我的意思是，这就是人们对它的评价，好吧，好吧，多米尼克，这就是人们对它的评价，这就是它现在的看法，当时并不是，因为当然有
romance i mean i don't want to gender stereotype but i'm going to yeah that girls tended to like the romance and boys tended to like the spectacle of large engines and ships crashing and everything. The funnels. Yeah. And it was a success across, you know, everybody watched it. Everybody liked it. Otherwise, it wouldn't have become the biggest grossing film of all time. Yeah. The film that replaces it in that list is the Lord of the Rings trilogy.
浪漫，我的意思是，我不想进行性别刻板印象，但我会，是的，女孩倾向于喜欢浪漫，男孩倾向于喜欢大型引擎和船只碰撞等等的奇观。烟囱。是的。它在各方面都很成功，你知道，每个人都看了。每个人都喜欢它。否则，它就不会成为有史以来票房最高的电影。是的。在那个名单上取代它的电影是《指环王》三部曲。
But you have to combine them to get to that point, don't you? Which we would do, Tom, naturally. But the thing is about the Lord of the Rings, it kind of retains a status, I think one might say. And here I am quoting from a brilliant podcast, Sentimental Garbage, which kind of looks at stuff basically that women like that men don't. Hold on. There are other brilliant podcasts. Unbelievable. It's very, very funny. Well, so Caroline O'Donoghue, the novelist, a cork woman. Okay. Very good. Yeah.
但你必须把它们结合起来才能达到那个点，不是吗？我们会自然而然地这样做，汤姆。但关于《指环王》的事情是，它保留了一种地位，我想人们可能会说。在这里，我引用了一个精彩的播客《感伤垃圾》，它基本上关注女性喜欢而男性不喜欢的那些东西。等等。还有其他精彩的播客。难以置信。它非常非常有趣。好吧，所以卡罗琳·奥多诺霍，那位小说家，一位科克女性。好吧。非常好。是的。
So you love a cork woman. Right. And they do a kind of great look at this. And her argument essentially is that Lord of the Rings retains its status because boys like it. And Titanic is condemned as kind of romantic slush because it's a thing for teenage girls. And they also do great stuff about this whole thing that the ship has an enormous phallus. They kind of turn this, as it on its head right and say no actually the ship is is rose the kate winslet character okay that both of them are escaping the patriarchal hold so what do you make of that what do you think of that you're absolutely convinced they're not overthinking
所以你喜欢科克女性。对。她们对这个进行了很好的观察。她的论点本质上是，《指环王》保留了它的地位，因为男孩们喜欢它。而《泰坦尼克号》被谴责为一种浪漫的垃圾，因为它是十几岁女孩的东西。她们还做了很多关于这艘船有一个巨大的阴茎的整件事。她们把这个颠倒过来，说不，实际上这艘船是露丝，那个凯特·温斯莱特的角色，好吧，她们俩都在逃避父权制的控制，所以你对此有何看法，你觉得怎么样，你绝对确信她们没有过度解读
it at all but it's a brilliant example of how the idea of the Titanic as a metaphor can be reinterpreted and reinterpreted. It can indeed, yeah. In very, very satisfying ways. If it's not a phallus or it's not an example of female emancipation, it's Europe before the First World War, isn't it? Or it's the British Empire. In fact, in Nazi propaganda, it often features as a kind of metaphor for Britain.
它一点也不，但这是一个关于泰坦尼克号作为隐喻的想法如何被重新诠释和再诠释的绝佳例子。它确实可以，是的。以非常非常令人满意的方式。如果它不是一个阴茎，或者它不是女性解放的例子，它是第一次世界大战前的欧洲，不是吗？或者它是大英帝国。事实上，在纳粹宣传中，它经常作为英国的一种隐喻。
It's industrial capitalism. I mean, now I'm guessing that it would serve as a metaphor for everything that is kind of destroying the world. Yeah. That idea of not having lifeboats, but having gyms and kind of luxury spas. Well, that's sort of your capitalism point, I suppose, isn't it? So I think the two most potent of those. So first of all all i think the fact
它是工业资本主义。我的意思是，现在我猜它会作为一个隐喻，代表所有正在摧毁世界的东西。是的。那种没有救生艇，但有健身房和豪华水疗中心的想法。好吧，我想那是你的资本主义观点，不是吗？所以我认为其中两个最有效的。所以首先，我认为事实
that it's two years before the first world war is colossally important in explaining why it has endured i mean it would endure anyway as a great story i mean when we did our live stream about disasters for the subscribers context is important isn't it context really matters because some of those disasters are unbelievably harrowing we did did the Victoria Hall disaster in Sunderland where hundreds of children were killed and most people had never heard of it. And the reason is because it doesn't stand for anything beyond itself, particularly. It's just a terrible accident. Titanic, because it's 1912 and because the world is going to fall apart in 1914, it's always bundled in with those shots
它发生在第一次世界大战前两年，这在解释它为什么能持久方面非常重要，我的意思是，作为一个伟大的故事，它无论如何都会持久，我的意思是，当我们为订阅者直播关于灾难的内容时，背景很重要，不是吗？背景真的很重要，因为其中一些灾难令人难以置信地痛苦，我们在桑德兰做了维多利亚大厅灾难，数百名儿童被杀，大多数人从未听说过它。原因是因为它除了自身之外并没有代表什么，特别是。这只是一场可怕的事故。泰坦尼克号，因为它是在1912年，而且因为世界将在1914年分崩离析，它总是被捆绑在那些镜头里
in Sarajevo that kick off the first world war I think I mean we love a cliched metaphor on the rest is history this is your absolute classic dancing on the edge of an abyss the storm clouds of war are gathering and the iceberg is heading south exactly so iceberg, exactly. So there's that. And I think that's understandable because what is coming in the 1910s is a colossal smash-up, to use the lingo of the time, of European civilization to some degree. Right. And another ocean line in the Lusitania will famously be sunk. Exactly. By a German submarine.
在萨拉热窝引发第一次世界大战的那些镜头，我想，我的意思是，我们喜欢在《历史的其余部分》中使用陈词滥调的隐喻，这是你绝对经典的在深渊边缘跳舞，战争的乌云正在聚集，冰山正在向南移动，完全正确，所以冰山，完全正确。所以有那个。而且我认为这是可以理解的，因为1910年代即将到来的是一场巨大的粉碎，用当时的话说，在某种程度上是欧洲文明的粉碎。对。另一艘远洋客轮卢西塔尼亚号也将被著名地击沉。完全正确。被德国潜艇。
And then the other thing is the awoke bishop, the Bishop of Winchester, saying it's about greed and hubris and it's capitalism. And I guess that is the one that ultimately will be the more enduring. Because you're absolutely right. We now in the 21st century are obsessed with that metaphor, aren't we? Because we are so conscious of our own civilization being imperiled by climate change and all these kinds of things. So the idea of this great luxurious, but actually the thing is, Titanic is very luxurious, but as you said, it is ultimately an emigrant ship. I mean, that's the thing. Well, so Dominic, you are a man who, when you hear a philosopher talk about a stone, likes to go up and kick it. I profute it thus, exactly. What is your take on all this? Do you think it has a profound metaphorical heft? No, ultimately.
然后另一件事是觉醒的主教，温彻斯特主教，说这是关于贪婪和傲慢，这是资本主义。我想这最终会是更持久的一个。因为你是绝对正确的。我们现在在21世纪对那个隐喻着迷，不是吗？因为我们非常意识到我们自己的文明正受到气候变化和所有这些事情的威胁。所以这个巨大的豪华的想法，但实际上，泰坦尼克号是非常豪华的，但正如你所说，它最终是一艘移民船。我的意思是，就是这样。好吧，所以多米尼克，你是一个当听到哲学家谈论石头时，喜欢走过去踢它的人。我就是这样反驳它的，完全正确。你对此有何看法？你认为它有深刻的隐喻分量吗？不，最终。
You just think it's a ship that hit an iceberg. I'll amaze you, Tom. Okay. So clearly, as I said before, I think a similar disaster was clearly going to happen given the extremely by modern standards lacks health and safety regulation that's what health and safety culture exists for is to make sure there are enough lifeboats but that said i think actually that when you get closer and closer into the story what you're confronted with is actually the meaninglessness of it and it's the fact that it doesn't have a meaning, I think, that is more frightening. Because I don't think it's a metaphor. Well, it is, but I think- It's both, isn't it? It's ultimately, on a human level, it's more frightening as the eruption of the unforeseen, of that thing that can destroy your life in an instant. And these people, the Colliers,
你只是认为它是一艘撞上冰山的船。我会让你惊讶的，汤姆。好吧。所以很明显，正如我之前所说，考虑到以现代标准来看极其宽松的健康和安全法规，类似的灾难显然会发生，这就是健康和安全文化存在的原因，是为了确保有足够的救生艇，但话虽如此，我认为实际上，当你越来越接近这个故事时，你所面对的实际上是它的无意义，而且我认为它没有意义的事实更令人恐惧。因为我不认为它是一个隐喻。好吧，它是，但我认为——它是两者，不是吗？它最终，在人类层面上，作为不可预见事物的爆发，作为那种可以在瞬间摧毁你生活的事物，它更令人恐惧。而这些人，科利尔一家，
they could have bought hundreds of tickets on ocean liners. And it was bloody bad luck that they bought one on a ship that itself suffered very bad luck because had they been on the other ships, they all didn't have enough lifeboats either. And yet they still made it back and it was fine. And it's just the terror of chance. That's my view. But you are a great man. You love a bit of meaning. I mean, I think you could say that the confidence to go slamming out across the ocean with all these wealthy fittings, sublimely confident that everything will be all right, that perhaps that is expressive of something of the spirit that leads Europe to war. If you wanted to, you could kind of push that. I agree. I mean, I think it is ultimately expressive of the spirit that leads Europe to war. If you wanted to, you could kind of push that. I agree. I mean, I think it is ultimately expressive of the fact that terrible things happen and that there isn't really a kind of a framing explanation beyond the fact that an iceberg broke off the ice sheet and at a particular moment happened to be where it was. But having said that,
他们本可以买数百张远洋客轮的票。他们买了一张本身运气非常不好的船的票，真是倒霉，因为如果他们在其他船上，它们也都没有足够的救生艇。然而他们还是回来了，一切都很好。这只是偶然的恐怖。这是我的观点。但你是一个伟大的人。你喜欢一点意义。我的意思是，我认为你可以说，带着所有这些昂贵的配件，极其自信地冲向海洋，相信一切都会好起来的信心，也许这表达了导致欧洲走向战争的精神。如果你愿意，你可以推动这一点。我同意。我的意思是，我认为它最终表达了导致欧洲走向战争的事实。如果你愿意，你可以推动这一点。我同意。我的意思是，我认为它最终表达了可怕的事情会发生，而且除了冰山从冰盖上断裂并在特定时刻恰好出现在那里之外，并没有一个框架性的解释。但话虽如此，
I don't deny that with the sinking happening, its power as a metaphor is incredibly profound. And that's why people keep using it. That's why we've done the podcast. Because if it didn't have that resonance, I don't think people would be interested in it. Well, I think it's the combination of the mythic resonance of the ship and this leviathan that's been produced by the world's first industrial nation in collaboration with the world's rising financial superpower, the United States. So there's that side to it.
我不否认随着沉船事件的发生，它作为隐喻的力量是非常深刻的。这就是为什么人们不断使用它。这就是为什么我们做了这个播客。因为如果它没有那种共鸣，我不认为人们会对它感兴趣。好吧，我认为这是船的神话共鸣与世界上第一个工业国家与世界上新兴的金融超级大国美国合作产生的这个利维坦的结合。所以有那一面。
But also, for me, reading the stories, it's the human details that will linger in my mind. You know, that kid who'd put on his trousers. I know, I know, I know. I mean, it's a ludicrous story, but those trousers really do kill him. Yeah. I mean, on his birthday. It has been given for his birthday. Terrible.
但对我来说，阅读这些故事，萦绕在我脑海中的是人类的细节。你知道，那个穿上裤子的孩子。我知道，我知道，我知道。我的意思是，这是一个荒谬的故事，但那些裤子确实杀了他。我的意思是，在他生日那天。这是他生日那天给他的。太可怕了。
Anyway, I think it's good to finish on that note of a boy who celebrates his birthday on the last day he's going to be alive, gets given a pair of long trousers, and is so proud of them that he refuses to take his chance to get on the ship. And I think we should finish with him. So thank you for listening to, I mean, it's been a Titanic series, hasn't it? with him. Yeah. So thank you for listening to, I mean, it's been a Titanic series, hasn't it? Six episodes. Yeah.
总之，我认为以一个男孩在他活着的一天庆祝生日，得到一条长裤，并为之感到自豪，以至于他拒绝抓住机会上船来结束这个故事是很好的。我认为我们应该以他结束。所以感谢收听，我的意思是，这是一个泰坦尼克式的系列，不是吗？和他一起。是的。所以感谢收听，我的意思是，这是一个泰坦尼克式的系列，不是吗？六集。是的。
You really couldn't have reached for another word there, Tom. You just thought I'd go for it. I know, I know. And to those of you who have stayed with us. Yeah. You're still alive. Well done. We have hit the iceberg of time.
你真的找不到另一个词了，汤姆。你只是觉得我会去用它。我知道，我知道。对于那些一直陪伴我们的人。是的。你还活着。干得好。我们已经撞上了时间的冰山。
Oh God. But guess what? You see, the thing is when they got to the united states a new journey lay ahead for many of them they did probably by railroad so another journey awaits you if you like having got off the boat you can get onto the exciting railroad that sets off next week and that railroad tom carries the name martin luther because you will be taking us through the extraordinarily colourful and world-changing life of arguably history's most exciting, what would we describe him as? I was about to say history's most exciting theologian, but I'm worried we won't have any
哦，上帝。但你猜怎么着？你看，当他们到达美国时，对他们中的许多人来说，一段新的旅程在前方，他们可能是乘火车旅行的，所以如果你喜欢下船，另一段旅程在等着你，你可以登上下一周出发的激动人心的铁路，那条铁路，汤姆，承载着马丁·路德的名字，因为你将带我们了解可以说历史上最激动人心的，我们会怎么形容他？我正要说历史上最激动人心的神学家，但我担心我们不会有任何
listeners. He changes the world. He changes the world. He changes Europe and he changes the world he changes the world he changes Europe and he changes the world and we will be making that argument next week when we look at how the Protestant Reformation begins in the early 16th century
听众。他改变了世界。他改变了世界。他改变了欧洲，他改变了世界，他改变了世界，他改变了欧洲，他改变了世界，我们将在下周讨论新教改革如何在16世纪初开始时提出这个论点
there's theological tracts there's fighting dogs there's poor behaviour on all sides the devil is present enormous amount of bowel related
有神学论文，有斗狗，各方都有糟糕的行为，魔鬼在场，大量的肠道相关
yeah commentary so all to come yeah so that's next week's journey but thank you for joining us on this particular voyage. And we'll see you next time. Bye-bye.
是的，评论，所以一切都将来临，是的，所以那是下周的旅程，但感谢你加入我们的这次特别航行。我们下次见。再见。
Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《娱乐的其余部分》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你它是如何运作的。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。那是therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。